vous savez vous allez voir mais détruire
ma légende la même chose avec yves saint
laurent puisque j'ai connu saint orens
le jour où il a rencontré la gloire
c'est à dire en janvier 58 qui succédait
à christian dior et présenté sa première
collection la collection trapèze et
j'étais là donc c'est vrai qu'il ya eu
besoin de moi après et c'est vrai que je
ne suis pas pour rien dans la réussite
de cette maison et de cette vraie
légende alors oui milliers la légende du
saint laurent
il ya aussi une coquetterie à vouloir
dire je ne suis pas numéro mais je suis
le numéro 2 par rapport à buffet on sait
les liens d'amitié qui qui vous ont uni
tu peux être une séparation mais c'est
votre
c'est votre affaire on sait aussi qu'il
ya eu 10 heures que vous avez connu et
qu'il y ait eu marc bolland qui a été
préféré à yves saint laurent et vous
étiez quand même à ce commencement alors
oui à ce moment là à ce moment là bien
sûr lorsque la maison christian dior a
décidé de ne pas de ne pas accepter
qu'il saluera continue chez elle et
finalement la renvoyer il fallait bien
faire face est la seule chose qu'on
pouvait faire c'était de créer une
maison de couture
je savais rien du tout ça vous savez
c'était pour moi un monde mystérieux
étranger fait d'élégance et de passer et
j'étais plutôt portée vers l'activité l
avenir et pour autant et il me semblait
que diriger une maison de couture ne
veut pas être si difficile que ça en
tout cas il fallait en faire l'essai
alors j'en ai fait l'essai
[Musique]